have fun with it oh she is
[Laughter]
brainy spears has posted yet another
playful video on instagram
and no we're not talking about this
[Music]
or this
this time the pop icon decided to be
quote annoying as hell to her boyfriend
sam
askari okay so my boyfriend has no idea
that i'm
filming him right now if you couldn't
tell by that extreme close-up
that's britney playfully plotting
against her bf
just like a normal couple in the
instagram video sam
is taking a nap or well he was until the
singer had
other plans for her man's peaceful
snooze okay so my boyfriend has no
idea that i'm filming him right now
[Laughter]
brittany was obviously having too much
fun
but we gotta give props to sam for
keeping his cool
after brit woke him up he was nothing
but smiles
[Laughter]
and get this brett even dropped some
love advice in the caption explaining
the key to a happy relationship is to be
annoying as hell
that's really important just to spread
joy you know and
be a happy person a good person the
video comes shortly after britt showed
off some new body art
the 38 year old singer rocked a
snakeskin bikini while getting
carried away with hannah tattoos it's
really kind of cool
she paired the post with another pic of
herself rocking a bohemian look
britney captioned it not sure what my
hands on my hips are about
i guess i'm demanding attention well
brett we think you said it best